I’m Krissette.
And I’m Kenise.
We watched Shrek.
The movie’s about...
(laughing)
Shrek and Donkey getting Fiona.
He wants children and to get married.
No, he wants his swamp.
Yeah, my swamp!
Shrek.
Because he has the grumpy feet.
and he always has the grumpy voice.
Shrek!
Donkey!
What?
She’s dramatic.
You can't do this to me, Shrek.
I'm too young for you to die.
And because she always faints.
To have confidence and
to  be yourself,
and to be okay with that.
Because...
Oh!
It's funny.
The Gingerbread Man did this.
Now tell me,
where are the others?
Eat me! (spits)
(laughing)
When you sell your movie
and you get rewards.
No.
The people that made the sound of
the characters get awards.
(in unison)
I'll give Shrek an award
for music.
(laughing)
(in unison)
You’re welcome. Goodbye.